he's an Indian businessman investor and
philanthropist he was a chairman of the
Tata Group a Mumbai based company from
1991 to 2012 the current revenues of the
Tata companies taken together are over
100 billion dollars annually
he's Ratan Tata and here his top 10
rules for success far more is gained by
walking on the shop floor and talking to
the people in trying to communicate one
of my weaknesses has been oh I think
I've never communicated and now for
adequately with our people partly
because I'm a shy person and secondly
because I didn't realize the importance
of communication but I think
communication with the employees is an
exceedingly important function that any
company chairman has to as to do and be
visible in that sense the great success
is the large companies of this world and
there are many and many successful
companies or are they the companies that
took chances where individuals started
in garages where ideas were born where
did Microsoft when did Apple waited
Amazon where did Google where did
Facebook come from they came from ideas
that people felt something could be done
and that they could make a difference
except my grandmother filly so I came I
could her she was ooh and I stayed in
the United States my life probably would
have been very different
I was very happy there very comfortable
had a very satisfying job and when I
came back here the first I mentioned the
first eight years were frustration my
masters thought that the best way to
teach me how to operate when I don't
think anyone if I thank and partly I
would be mr. Jerry cutter successor so I
was on the shop floor
shoveling limestone working the furnaces
and I kept asking myself why am I doing
this
and so perhaps looking back the most
significant incident in my life for just
my obstinacy to remain here other than
to go back my view is that Trust is an
underlying foundation for for the way
people look at you people look at your
business people look at the way you
operate your business Trust is the basis
on which you live by your contractual
obligations and I think Trust is more
important than anything else your
psychological bond with your customer
and your your worker and your
stakeholders in general I think without
that you run the risk of of being a
superficial business entrepreneur based
on on criteria which are not in fact
truly fundamental to the manner in which
you do business
because globally uh Indians whether
government or businessmen don't quite
have the reputation of being the most
ethical failure unfairly I don't know
whether one can generalize but I would
just say that if you don't have trust in
your partner in your worker in your
management and vice versa if they don't
trust in the person at the top either
for what he or she stands for or what
their value system is then you have a
business that that supports that level
of trust or lack of trust and that goes
all the way to to the consumer he
doesn't trust you for what you provide
him he doesn't believe in your claims
and you have in fact a poorer form of
business and yet ethics and values
becomes a very major part of it if you
think you cannot make a difference I'd
say you very well can make a difference
if you so desire that you are humble as
you look forward if you would if you
speak or sit next to a Nobel laureate he
never tells you that he won a Nobel
Prize other people tell you so let you
millet EB yoke your best I don't know
one one hero I've always had it no
longer lives as has been John Kennedy oh
yes of course I was very much in the US
at that time a person stands out still
as very much money my hero at that time
and continues to get me emotionally
nostalgic about the days I that's true
that I was there I mentioned when you
took over that many many external
observers they thought you had large
shoes to fill on taking over from your
uncle now with another
of power Cyrus Pallonji Mistry has his
own lodge used to fill that of yourself
I wonder what advice you would give
Cyrus as he takes takes on his task as
chairman I've told Cyrus that he needs
to be his own person that finally was
something I did now I realized the shoes
that I had to fill were far too big for
me to mimic the person ever
I was following and I just decided that
just be myself and do what I thought was
right would be the way to go
I've told Cyrus the same thing I think
he he should feel that he is being his
own person and let his personality and
his conscience if you might drive him
and you shouldn't merely consider
yourself successful based on the
prosperity you gained for yourself but
you should go home at night feeling
satisfied if you have made a difference
that difference is something each one of
us can make and will have will have
failures and we've had frustrations but
it's a continued commitment that we have
to the world around us my own personal
feeling is that it is not a threat
provided provided it is looked at this
as a driver for competition in the
driver for in over
are you an Indian company I'll take the
automobile industry as an example
despite the fact that we produce about
two million cars a year there are only
two manufactures two manufacturers of
India classes Mahindra and others every
other international manufacturers here
in one form or another is there are
disadvantages because scale etc is far
bigger in the foreign manufactures but
if you look before that the 50 years of
automobiles we had two manufacturers who
never increase the production for more
than 50 thousand cars who never changed
their model who never innovated who
never gave the market anything other
than what they produce in the market is
bought what they did you waited seven
years for a car ten years for a car so
if you look at the two two examples has
in here benefited I would say yes we
would do the two new manufacturers gain
anything from this open market yes
because we're driven to to compete with
those
people in the daily look at that they're
meant to drive us out I think we as a
nation would lose out all of you have
been trained to be innovative hopefully
I'll do the MNCs when they come here
it's our job as employers to encourage
you to do that to encourage you to break
new ground to to think think out of the
box and it's for you to do it and for us
to support it so I don't think we should
look at energies as a threat I think we
should look at them with them as a
motivator to be more competitive and
beat them the greatest pleasure I've had
is trying to do something that everybody
says could not be done I just share
perhaps perhaps say a moment in time
which I will always cherish I decided
that India could produce its own car
everybody
my friends are overseas in the
automobile business said that this
couldn't be done we had to go through a
collaboration to get know how to get
technology but we undertook to produce
this car you saw images of it in the
video it was called the indica and we
produced it in India totally of Indian
content as we as we got close to putting
it in the market my friends in India so
a distance themselves remain otherwise
known as distancing yourself from
failure
and when the car came out I suddenly
felt that I didn't have a friend in the
world and that all the warnings that
people had given me were probably going
to come true but the car did come out it
did are in a twenty percent market share
and we showed that we could do something
throughout throughout the time I've been
involved in business there hasn't been
anything that has equaled the excitement
the reward and the exhilaration that the
car industry has provided and can't
provide thank you so much for watching I
made this video because high/low asked
me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of the top ten rules had the
biggest impact on you leave it in the
comments I will join the discussion
thank you so much for watching he seems
to believe and I'll see you soon